the frozen easter egg everyone missed
secret sacrifices and my theory on the
real reason olof knows his name
are just a few of the biggest reveals in
once upon a snowman
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and today
i'm explaining the biggest new frozen
details we discovered in olof's short
film on disney plus
once upon a snowman is a frozen mid-qual
that reveals the origins of olaf between
the time
elsa creates him and when he meets anna
and kristoff
the short film begins during let it go
and as olof comes to life
we discover it's actually elsa's cape
and her iconic the cold never bothered
me anyway moment which sends him rolling
down the mountain setting him on the
path that eventually leads him to honor
i'm alive who said that after pondering
the nature of his existence olaf wanders
over to oaken's trading post
he hears kristoff seeing reindeer are
better than people and arrives just as
honour's leaving
as olaf enters we see oaken putting up
honors coronation dress for sale which
reveals she must have been short of cash
and decided to trade her expensive royal
dress in return for the tools and
carrots christoph couldn't afford plus
her winter attire
this also explains the missing detail
from the original movie as to why honor
left oakens wearing a purple skirt
rather than the green one she had on
originally after entering the trading
post olaf remarks on the hidden meaning
of its name
wandering oakens do you know that if you
scramble up those letters it's an
anagram for naked norwegians
this fun little joke appears to be the
secret easter egg from the first frozen
movie that disney producer peter
delbecco said people on the internet
hadn't picked up on
and if you're thinking like me that olaf
didn't learn to read until frozen too
okay olaf you're up so much easier now
that i can read well disney went right
ahead and lampshaded us by acknowledging
this inconsistency
and i can't even read i genuinely don't
know how i just did that
at oakens we also discover where olof's
love of summertime came
from oh i don't know why but i've always
loved the idea of
summer when the shopkeeper puts a
stereoscope on the little snowman's face
and shows him a series of pictures
what is this that would be of summer
summer it's beautiful there's some cool
easter eggs here and interestingly many
of the images olaf sees appear later in
the main frozen movie when he sings in
summer
for example the red and orange parasol
and the green and white striped ball are
the same ones we see in the song when
olaf is imagining himself sunbathing on
the beach
and the slide with the bees and the
purple and yellow flowers as well as the
dandelions in this picture all appear
during this moment from in
the summer kids will blow dandelion fuzz
this image of a meadow and bandstand is
from the moment in the song where olaf
sings together with seagulls in a
tribute to birch from mary poppins
and this red checkered blanket pops up
in the original film
and again in the sequel i've never
identified with anything so much in my
whole life it's like snowmen in summer
just
belong together the short also reveals
that olaf was the original cause of the
wolf chase scene in the first frozen
movie
the summer sausage that oaken gives him
for a nose attracts unwanted attention
from a pack of wolves and
as he attempts to escape the hungry
horde he wishes past behind honor and
christoph
that commotion seems to be why kristoff
stopped the sled in the first movie and
that
caused the wolf pack to notice him in
honor and switch to chasing them instead
of olaf
it's during olaf's escape from the
wolves that he first discovers how he
can disassemble and rearrange himself at
will
and falling apart
there's some great physical humor in
these scenes and we can see how he
learns to control his stick hands
independently of his body a skill that
we first saw him use when he slapped
kristoff after meeting him
in the first film how does this work ow
stop it sven try and focus here
the short also reveals olaf's noble and
selfless side when he decides to donate
his sausage nose to a hungry wolf
you need this even more than i do
chronologically this is the first
example of how olaf is willing to
sacrifice his own wants and well-being
for the sake of somebody else
as he does later for ana in the main
movie after she's been cruelly abandoned
by hans
love is putting someone else's needs
before yours olaf
you're melting some people are worth
melting for
and as a token of appreciation for
olof's sacrifice the wolf gives the
snowman a friendly warm lick and a
cuddle
that felt just like a warm hug this is
olaf's first experience of the warm hugs
he's so fond of telling everyone about
in the frozen movies
i'm olaf and i like warm hugs good
afternoon i am olaf please let me finish
and i like warm hugs i like more mugs
and as olaf thinks about that warm hug
we discover that he's able to hear elsa
and honors voices from years ago
these voices are from the first frozen
when elsa and honor were little
do you want to go to snowman
my theory on the reason why olaf can
hear these voices from before he was
even alive is because he's made of snow
and ice which are of course frozen water
and as was established in frozen two
water has
memory and it seems that because olaf is
made from elsa's ice magic he's able to
connect to her memories
we then find out that this memory is how
olaf discovers his name
i'm olaf and i like warm
hugs basically he's recalling the name
that elsa gave to the snowman that she
and honor built as kids
hi i'm olaf and i look warm hugs as the
short film ends we see olaf spot honor
kristoff and sven near the frozen lake
and waterfall in the distance
he may be noseless at this moment but it
shows us how he ends up
wandering over to meet them in the first
movie and
now when anna gives him a carrot for a
nose in the main film olof's reaction
makes even more sense after the events
of once upon a snowman
are you okay are you kidding me i am
wonderful i've always wanted a nose so
did you like
olaf's new origin story and once upon a
snowman and did you spot any other
interesting details in the short film
leave your thoughts in the comments
below if you enjoyed these details do
leave a thumbs up and
tap left for another frozen video or tap
right for something else you're sure to
like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippie kai movie lovers